[Música]
no es una estrella del rock es gustavo
petro quieres ser presidente de colombia
y hace campaña en el pueblo en el que
nació
100 nada de oro donde hasta los ciegos
bailan por verle
[Aplausos]
el evento se llama petro escucha los
asistentes le plantean propuestas
como diana varela representante de un
grupo de mujeres cocineras
formando marca en grande lo tengo en
frente de la
tomé
ciénaga de oro es un municipio cerca del
mar caribe ilusiona la posibilidad de
tener el primer presidente del
departamento de córdoba
los orígenes de gustavo petro son
humildes
sus primos enseñan la casa en la que
nació hoy es la sede del partido al poco
de nacer
gustavo se fue a vivir cerca de bogotá
pero nunca dejó de volver
era de pocas palabras muy tímidos pero
las pocas conversaciones que forjaba con
uno tenía esa orientación del líder
es probable que contenga algunas en la
zona también quedan viejos compañeros de
lucha pacho rodríguez perteneció la
extinta guerrilla del m-19 a la que
petro se incorporó en 1977 se
desmovilizaron en 1990 tras un acuerdo
de paz petro representa los valores del
m-19 expresado en
paz
justicia trabajo y democracia hoy
tuviera 60 años de edad pero más de 30
años después muchos no olvidan su pasado
gustavo laca es médico y fue alcalde de
ciénaga de oro en dos ocasiones
a su hermano lo mato el m-19 y los
criminales no son ex criminales
los criminales háganse siempre
criminales gustavo petro acaba la
jornada con un mitin y
rodeado de seguridad y acompañado por
miles de fieles pretende romper con la
historia para convertirse en el primer
presidente de izquierda de colombia
[Aplausos]